what happened this week to the CSM at
Von tobel Middle School was tragic what
we can't prevent a stray bullet coming
from a surrounding area of a school we
can definitely be prepared if there is a
random act of violence on our campus
that was a member of the education
support employees Association as the
Clark County School Board voted to raise
the pay for campus security monitors on
the monitor was shot by a stray bullet
in what sources are saying close to the
investigation was a gang-related
incident an 18 year old was charged with
several counts of attempted murder now
the school board also expressed some
concern tonight over the high number of
student absences administrators
presented a survey showing it is a
district-wide problem currently there
are 108 schools the district is
considering having chronic absenteeism
what that means is leaders will knock in
the homes of students notifying parents
in person of those absences but Mike
Barton an administrator says despite
that effort truancy isn't getting any
better
we've heard that loud and clear from
principles they're doing that work and
doing it according to the code of
conduct
but then then what
then at the end of the day they issue
they can continue truancy notices all
day long but nothing's happening there's
not a consequence this school year
nearly half of African-American students
in CCSD are considered as chronically
absent district-wide one in three
students have high absences